[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
sozusagen wir machen heute weiter bei
der schlimmsten Terrorattacke in der
deutschen Nachkriegsgeschichte das ist
der Anschlag auf das Münchner
Oktoberfest am 26 September 1980 ich bin
Toni Heyer und ich bin Mirco Kasimir wir
wollen heute darüber sprechen ob der
Neonazi Gundolf Köhler wirklich ein
Einzeltäter war und was er mit dem
Anschlag bezwecken wollte bei dem außer
ihm 12 Menschen starben und mehr als 200
verletzt wurden heute kommen aber
erstmal auch Opfer zu Wort Menschen die
dieses Grauen überlebt haben sie trafen
sich an einem regnerischen Tag im Herbst
2020 um 40 Jahre nach dem Anschlag
gemeinsam an das Leid zu erinnern aber
auch an die Kraft weiterzumachen
mit dabei Robert höckmayer dessen
Familie an diesem Abend im Jahr 1980
zerstört wurde für uns Überlebende ist
jeder Tag in 26 September
wir können vielleicht einiges verdrängen
doch vergessen können wir nicht
so habe ich zwei Geschwister direkt bei
Anschlag verloren 40 Jahre gedenken das
ist für mich daher vor allem ein Denken
an 40 Jahre ungeliebtes leben
für uns Überlebende geht das Leben
jedoch weiter trotz aller Schmerzen doch
dafür brauchen wir eine helfende Hand
die den Rückweg ins Leben erleichtert
gerade in den vergangenen Jahren hat
hier zum Glück endlich ein Umdenken im
Umgang mit Überlebenden von Terrorakten
begonnen Renate Martinez wurde der
Rücken und ein Fuß zerfetzt mein Name
ist Renate Martinez
in der Nacht des
rechtsextremen Terroranschlags war ich
auf dem Heimweg denn ich wollte tags
darauf mit Freunden zum Bergsteigen
gehen doch um 22:20 Uhr schleuderte die
Bombe Splitter in meine Lunge in meine
Beine
ich hatte später im Kopf ich hatte
tausend kleine Splitter am ganzen Körper
gesundheitlich begann für mich in dieser
Nacht ein harter Weg der heute wieder
unser schwerer wird
den Wunsch wieder laufen zu können
konnte ich mir nur durch meine Jugend
Ehrgeiz und hat es Training erfüllen
doch 40 Jahre später wünsche ich mir
Dinge die vor dem Attentat normal und
selbstverständlich waren die vor allen
Dingen meine persönliche
Bewegungsfreiheit einschränken
ich möchte endlich wieder auf einen Berg
steigen mit dem Radl um den Starnberger
See fahren
ich möchte einfach nur schmerzfrei 3
Stunden durch den Tierpark marschieren
oder beschwingtanzen
das Leid von Robert Meyer Renate
Martinez und hunderten anderen beginnt
am
26.09.1980 als der 21-Jährige Gundolf
Köhler eine selbstgebastelte Bombe am
Haupteingang des Oktoberfestes an der
Theresienwiese zündet schon seit seinem
14 Lebensjahr gilt er als glühender Nazi
Verehrer und war später auch auf den
Mitgliederlisten der rechtsextremen
Wehrsportgruppe Hoffmann zu finden die
Bombe aus TNT und einer
feuerlöscherkartusche hinterlässt deine
Spur des Grauens und zerfetzt den Täter
selbst bis zur Unkenntlichkeit
1980 gibt es noch keine breaking news
nicht mal ganze Sender die sich nur
Nachrichten widmen
aber die Tagesschau berichtet in ihrer
Hauptausgabe am nächsten Tag sehr
ausführlich über diesen Anschlag von
München wir hören mal rein die Bombe war
in einem Abfallkorb versteckt der
Sprengstoff etwa drei Kilo und hoch
brisant explodierte in einem
dickwandigen Gussrohr es entstand kein
Krater viel mehr wirkte die Bombe
flächig und deswegen so verheiratet der
Druck war in den umliegenden Test
zählten zu spüren der Knall noch in
mehreren Kilometern Entfernung zu hören
Rettungswagen und notarztfahrzeuge
fuhren 147 einsetze es dauert etwa eine
Stunde bis alle Verletzten in
Krankenhäusern untergebracht waren die
Polizei dritte Schaulustige zurück und
regelte den Tatort ab
ein Taxifahrer steht etwas geschehen so
es gab einen riesigen Feuerball das
ganze hat es Taxi und nicht Straße
unheimlich erschüttert
ich bin habe dann sofort überfunk
sämtliche not verfügbare Notärzte
angerufen oder herkommen lassen bin dann
rausgerannt und habe versucht die Leute
zu den schwer verletzten hin zu
dirigieren weil totale Konfession war
der bayerische Ministerpräsident Strauss
kam nach bekannt werden der Katastrophe
zur Theresienwiese an Ort und Stelle
informierte sich auch
Bundesjustizminister Vogel Strauß sprach
von einem hochlosen Anschlag der beweise
es im Kampf gegen Terror von welcher
Seite auch immer nicht nachgelassen
werden dürfen
war das ein rechtsextremer Anschlag und
war Köhler ein Einzeltäter
mit beiden Fragen tun sich Polizei und
Politik erstmal schwer auch das Motiv
bleibt rätselhaft man kann den Täter ja
nicht mehr befragen weil ein
Terroranschlag vorliegt übernimmt
Generalbundesanwalt Kurt Rebmann gleich
am 27 September 1980 die Ermittlungen
noch einen Tag später gibt er eine
Pressekonferenz nach dem bisherigen
Ermittlungen kommt als Täter der
21-Jährige geologiestudent Gundolf
Köhler aus Donaueschingen in Betracht er
kam bei dem einen Tat ums Leben seine
Verletzungen nämlich wurde beide Arme
abgerissen er hat erhebliche
Verletzungen im Brust und im
Bauchbereich er hat Versenden des
Haupthaar lassen darauf schließen dass
er sich bei der Explosion der Bombe in
deren unmittelbarer Nähe gefunden hat
wir gehen davon aus dass die Bombe zu
früh gezündet worden ist
Anhaltspunkte dafür dass Köhler
Selbstmord begehen wollte oder begangen
hat liegen nicht vor
wir nehmen nicht an beim gegenwärtlichen
Stand der Ermittlungen das Köhler als
alleintäter gehandelt hat der letzte
Satz birgt Sprengstoff und soll noch
jahrelang umstritten bleiben
Werbung du Marius ja ich liebe ja die
TV-Serie julia Leischik sucht bitte
melde dich die schaue ich ja am liebsten
mit meiner Mama zusammen denn in dieser
Serie geht es darum dass die Julia quasi
um die halbe Welt fliegt um vermisste
Menschen zu suchen und Familien die
lange Zeit voneinander getrennt waren
die wieder zusammenzuführen und das
macht sie jetzt schon seit sage und
schreibe 18 Jahren und ich kann dir eins
sagen bei uns auf der Couch daheim
bleibt
Auge trocken das kann ich mir sehr gut
vorstellen aber raquelle weißt du was es
gibt das ganze nämlich jetzt auch zum
Hören im brandneuen Podcast Julia
Leischik spurlos echt jetzt erzähl mir
mehr ja jede Woche gibt es einen neuen
rätselhaften und emotionalen fallen wie
du das kennst Julia erzählt das zusammen
im Podcast aber mit ihrem langjährigen
Kollegen Michael Strasser und ich finde
da hört man sofort das ist eine
eingeschworenes Team ne die beiden die
sind schon seit so vielen Jahren da
zusammen unterwegs fürs Fernsehen reisen
um die ganze Welt um diese Vermissten zu
suchen da hörst du einfach das ist
natürlich auch Freunde geworden sind
aber nicht nur die beiden kommen zu Wort
sondern auch direkt betroffene
Angehörige Kriminalbeamte Experten und
die schildern dann alle ihre Sicht auf
den Fall also liefern sie quasi einen
Blick hinter die Kulissen genau ja also
man kann sagen das ist so eine True
Crime wie sie da den Fällen nachgehen
trifft auf große Emotionen wie ihr sie
liebt da zu Hause auf der Couch der
Podcast julia Leischik spurlos jeden
Mittwoch gibt es eine neue Folge also
hört auf jeden Fall rein und um keine
Folge zu verpassen abonniert die julia
Leischik spurlos kostenlos auf dem
Podcast Player eures Vertrauens
Werbung Ende
denn um es mal zu spoilern bis heute ist
nicht ein einziger Mittäter ermittelt
oder gar verhaftet worden aber die
Aktenlage kurz nach dem Anschlag sieht
sehr eindeutig aus
Redmann lässt 20 Mitglieder der
rechtsextremistischen Terrorgruppe
Wehrsportgruppe Hoffmann festnehmen
darunter sind vier Männer die am Tag des
Attentats mit einem Fahrzeugkonvoi aus
Bayern ausreisen wollten aber von
Österreichs Grenzschutz zurückgeschickt
worden waren in der Wohnung eines
Mitglieds findet man Granaten und
Sprengstoff bei Hoffmann selbst Munition
und zündkapseln aber die waffenexperten
des LKA finden keine direkten Bezüge zum
Attentat und angeblich haben alle
verdächtigen Alibis für den Abend des 26
September schon am 29.09 werden alle
wieder freigelassen dabei sprechen auch
Zeugenaussagen dafür dass Köhler nicht
allein gehandelt hat fünf Tage vor
Anschlag sieht eine Zeugin in einem Auto
mit dem Kennzeichen vs für
Villingen-Schwenningen vs dd500 im Wagen
sollen vorn zwei Männer hinten zwei
Männer und eine Frau gesessen haben der
Wagen sei eine Motorrad gefolgt das auf
das oktoberfestgelände fuhr weitere
Zeugen sehen Köhler ab etwa 21 Uhr vor
der Tat mit einem jungen Mann und einer
dunkelhaarigen etwa 18-Jährigen Frau am
Tabakwaren stand bei der brausebadinsel
das ist ein unmittelbarer Nähe zum
Tatort der Zeuge Frank lauter jung ist
sicher dass Köhler am Tatabend ab etwa
21:30 Uhr heftig mit zwei Männern
diskutiert hat die kurze stoppelhaare
hatten und Grüne Parker Drogen der
schwer verletzte Finanzbeamte Hans
Rohrauer bezeugt im Oktober 1980 im
Krankenhaus er habe wenige Meter neben
dem Papierkorb gestanden und ein dunkles
Auto mit mindestens drei Insassen aber
Bavaria Ring halten sehen
ein junger Mann den er als Gundolf
Köhler identifizierte sei mit einer
hellen Tüte in der Hand herangetreten
und habe etwa 30 bis 60 Sekunden lang
durch das offene Beifahrerfenster heftig
mit den Insassen diskutiert dann sei er
abrupt zum Papierkorb gegangen habe sich
darüber gebeugt und die Tüte vorsichtig
hineingelegt
alle diese Beobachtungen sprechen dafür
dass Köhler Helfer vielleicht auch
Hintermänner hatte Menschen die mit
planten die das Gelände mit ausspeten
die ihn am Abend dorthin fuhren
aber die Ermittlungen können keine
einzige dieser Spuren erhärten es ist
bestimmt auch nicht hilfreich den
kompletten Tatort schon am nächsten
Morgen wieder für die Besucher Besen
reinzumachen und das Oktoberfest ganz
normal weiterlaufen zu lassen ein Koffer
den Köhler unmittelbar vor der Tat bei
sich gehabt haben soll wird weder unter
den sicher gestellten asservaten noch an
anderer Stelle gefunden
eine weitere Spur sind 48
Zigarettenstummel die in Köhlers Auto
gefunden werden 36 sind laut dem
bka-labor anderen Blutgruppen zuzuordnen
als der Köhlers
es gab also Mitfahrer aber schon im
Februar 1981 lässt die Polizei alle
Beweise aus dem Auto vernichten genauso
erfolglos ist die Suche nach dem Motiv
mit Studenten Köhlers werden sowohl von
der Polizei als auch von einem Reporter
der Zeitschrift quick befragt sie
zeichnen einerseits das Bild eines
frustrierten Einzeltäters der gerade
Liebeskummer und Stress mit einer
Prüfung hatte und obendrauf auch noch
Geld sorgen
sie bestätigen aber auch Köhlers
rechtsradikale Tendenzen sein Interesse
für Militärkleidung und Waffenteile
einer der Kommilitonen Max Gärtner will
sich erinnern dass Köhler über
Wahlbeeinflussung durch Anschläge
geredet habe man könne solche Attentate
den Linken in die Schule schieben wie
sich später zeigen soll hat Köhler
keineswegs so viel Liebeskummer oder
Stress dass er aus purem Frust einen
Anschlag verüben würde was das mögliche
Motiv angeht wird die Theorie von damals
aber bis heute für wahrscheinlich
gehalten demnach beginnt Köhler den
Anschlag damit er Linksextremisten wie
der RAF in die Schuhe geschoben würde so
sollte sich die Stimmung gegen die SPD
wenden dass er selbst umkam und damit
als Täter ermittelt wurde ja das war ein
Versehen die Bombe zündete zu früh die
Polizei erfuhr somit dass ein Neonazi
der Täter war
und was wurde aus der Bundestagswahl tja
die Bundestagswahl die gewann Helmut
Schmidt von der SPD in der Diskussion am
Wahlabend also am 5 oktober 1980 freute
sich Parteichef Willy Brandt über das
Ergebnis und dreht sich mit dem Bayern
Franz Josef Strauß politisch gesprochen
die Wahl ging darum soll es mit bleiben
oder wird Strauss Bundeskanzler und das
Ergebnis ist ganz deutlich eine
verstärkte Mehrheit dafür dass Helmut
Schmidt weiterarbeitet
Helmut Schmidt hat die Wahl war Kanzler
gewonnen aber im pyrosiegerungen
die Probleme bleiben die Stunde der
Wahrheit kommt ich werde ich werde die
Stunde der Wahrheit
in ihrem Werdegang sehr aufmerksam
verfolgen ich denke gar nicht dran aus
der Bundespolitik auszuschreiben der
nächste Präsident eines großen Landes
ist größten flächenstaates
ermittlungstechnisch bleibt der Fall ein
Debakel ohne ihn wirklich gelöst zu
haben stellt das LKA seine
Untersuchungen im Mai 1981 ein
anderthalb Jahre später schließt auch
die Generalbundesanwaltschaft ihre Akten
Gundolf Köhler gilt als frustrierter
Einzeltäter und der Wehrsportgruppe
Hoffmann könne kein mitwirken
nachgewiesen werden die Bombenexplosion
gilt also nicht als politisch
motivierter Terroranschlag wie wir schon
im ersten Teil festgestellt hatten waren
die Ermittlungen politisch äußerst
brisant
so hatte ja der bayerische
Ministerpräsident Franz Josef Strauß der
Bundeskanzler werden wollte die
Wehrsportgruppe Hoffmann noch Anfang des
Jahres als er harmlose Spinner
dargestellt wäre es da nicht zu peinlich
gewesen wenn genau diese Spinner mitten
in Bayern den schlimmsten Terroranschlag
Deutschlands verübt hätten ist es da
nicht vielleicht viel eleganter wenn man
Gundolf Köhler als Einzeltäter
hinstellen kann auf jeden Fall ist die
Geschichte noch lange nicht zu Ende als
der Fall Anfang der 80er eingestellt
wird noch jahrelang kämpfen politische
Initiativen und Journalisten darum dass
der Anschlag auf das Oktoberfest
vollständig aufgeklärt wird und dass er
endlich als das anerkannt wird was er
war ein rechtsextremer Terroranschlag
immer wieder werden einzelne
Fehlleistungen der Ermittler in der
Öffentlichkeit diskutiert vernichtete
Beweise verschlammte Gewebeproben
verschwundene Fragmente einer
abgerissenen Hand
2006 gibt es einen Dokumentarfilm über
den Fall 2011 eine Landtagsdebatte und
im Jahr 2014 werden die Ermittlungen
offiziell wieder von Generalbundesanwalt
Harald Range aufgenommen
nochmals gibt es mehr als tausend
Vernehmungen nach fünfeinhalb Jahren
werden im Juli 2020 die Ermittlungen
eingestellt die offizielle Opferzahl
wird von 224 auf 234 erhöht trotz der
umfangreichen Nachforschungen werden
auch diesmal aber keine Mittäter
überführt aber im Gegensatz zu den
Ermittlungen der 80er Jahre bewertet die
Bundesanwaltschaft den Anschlag nicht
länger als unpolitisch sondern als eine
rechtsextremistisch motivierte Tat das
Schlusswort in diesem Fall überlassen
wir Robert höckmaier das ist der Mann
vom Anfang dieser Folge der Mann dessen
Familie am 26 September von der Bombe
eines Neonazis zerstört wurde innere
Sicherheit ist Kern Aufgabe staatlichen
Handelns
neben einem Gefühl
[Musik]
von Sicherheit ist aber auch vor allem
Gewissheit von Sicherheit entscheidend
so hatte ich all die Jahre immer nach
dem Warum dieses Anschlags gefragt mit
Ende der Ermittlungen der Soko in diesem
Jahr
ist die für mich so wichtige Frage jetzt
beantwortet das Attentat ist nun endlich
offiziell als rechtsextrem eingestuft
auch das Motiv ist geklärt dieser
Anschlag sollte die Bundestagswahlen
1980 beeinflussen
wer aber diese Demokratie Gewalt und
Bomben aushebeln will wird scheitern
und das war unser Fall für heute wir
hoffen es hat euch gefallen und wir
freuen uns natürlich auch wenn ihr uns
auf den Podcast Plattform folgt
Bewertungen hinterlasst und die Glocke
aktiviert oder natürlich uns Feedback
schreibt und das könnt ihr unter anderem
in die mir an Podcast ad Bild.de
schreibt oder uns auf Instagram folgt
und uns dort eine Nachricht hinterlasst
wir hören uns dann in der nächsten Folge
bis dahin macht's gut eure Tony und eure
Mirko wir haben den Fall rekonstruiert
aus dem Archiv des Axel Springer
Verlages aus Artikeln von Süddeutscher
Zeitung und Spiegel sowie der
Dokumentation der Stadt München von
Tatjana nees die posten wir als
downloadlinge auch in den Shownotes das
Skript hat Stefan Netzeband geschrieben
die Postproduktion erfolgte wie immer
durch die weight watch Studios München
Aufnahme und schnitt